delivering cargo hey there Sam glad you
can make it would've been satisfied just
having it but you had to go above and
beyond Sam a man good of you to drop in
again that's the picture of perfection
right there
without anyone but you could have pull
this off that's here how's it gone
kagaz in mint condition how the hell did
you manage that so
looks good as new my head's off you I
appreciate you going out of your way for
us Sam
but seriously what's your secret and
don't tell me it's tender love and care
I mean there's not even one single
scratch that's incredible
what we have here a delivery for me this
is in great shape
excellent work hello hello Oh a delivery
wonderful simply wonderful service
befitting a legend among porters hey Sam
how's it going damn you carried all this
by yourself
always a pleasure Sam this is pretty
good better than good oh there you are
everything all right
cargo is in perfect condition
looks like this is our lucky day hey Sam
Sam bridges welcome to our summer home
by the Falls oh well thanks for making
the trip I've always wanted to meet you
I know what you're thinking is that an
otter on my head or am I just happy to
see you well both actually the otter is
a member of the weasel family I have
weasels in my family but enough about my
brother man you are tough
howdy Sam
the legend sure does deliver on cargos
and damn near perfect condition now you
got it here looking like that I surely
do not know
[Music]